it is a tale of domestic abuse drug
binges and trashed properties in 2020
the so-called libel trial of the century
saw johnny depp sue the son over claims
he was a wife beater depp lost that one
but is now heading back to court to try
to clear his name here's everything you
need to know
this is an issue that's lasted years
johnny depp and amber heard started
dating back in 2011 after meeting on the
set of the rum diary they got married in
2015 but according to evidence that was
given in the 2020 trial the problem
started long before that
heard obtained a restraining order
against depp in 2016 and claimed that he
was physically abusive depp has denied
this they settled their divorce in 2017
but it was far from over
in 2018 the sun wrote a headline
describing depp as a wife beater he sued
the newspaper's publishers and after a
messy trial lost the case in november
2020 with the judge ruling that the
newspaper's article was substantially
true the actor was subsequently dropped
from the fantastic beasts films and
roles have since dried up
[Music]
the trial is focusing on another 2018
article this one written by amber heard
herself she wrote a column for the
washington post describing herself as a
public figure representing domestic
abuse she didn't mention debt by name
but he launched a 50 million defamation
lawsuit against herd in 2019. she has
since filed a counter claim for
defamation against depp accusing him of
a smear campaign after delays due to the
pandemic the trial is finally taking
place
despite both stars being based in
california the trial is taking place in
virginia that's because the washington
post's online editions are published
through servers in fairfax county
it is going to be a lengthy one set to
take place over seven weeks with a
week's break in may both depp and heard
are set to appear in person to give
their testimonies during the hearing and
they aren't the only high profile names
appearing james franco and elon musk are
set to give evidence for herd while paul
bettany is appearing for depp
family members security guards
assistants and others who worked around
the former couple are also on the
witness lists
one of the biggest differences between
this trial and the 2021 is that it's all
going to be televised cameras are
allowed in courtrooms in the u.s and the
judge has permitted filming for this one
it means you will be able to watch as
depp heard and their celebrity witnesses
give evidence and sky news will be
covering the case live online
the cost of this very public showdown
could be damaging for both in the court
of public opinion